hey guys today is going to be a quick
video on how to subscribe to rss feeds
in mozilla thunderbird so i'm going to
open up mozilla thunderbird to show you
i already subscribed to this is my tech
news section of
rss feeds and first of all in order to
add an rss feed account you go to file
and you select new
and account and you're going to make it
an rss news and blog account
go ahead and rename it
and hit next
and then you're going to finish it
well i'm going to cancel this because i
don't actually want to make one i
already made a tech news account so what
i'm going to do now is open up an
internet browser such as firefox
and i'm going to go and search for an
rss feed so i might search rss um
i don't know google news and a lot of
websites have rss feeds and when you
actually do find one i found one i like
this is the new york times homepage
it'll actually end instead of in dot com
or dot order net it'll end in dot xml
and that's how you know this is a
an actual rss feed so go ahead and
select the entire url
and copy it
then open up your
thunderbird again
and we're going to right click on the
tech news and subscribe
add one
and control v will paste that url into
the feed url what it's asking for store
articles and tech news and just show a
summary instead of loading a web page i
can load it if i'm interested
and then there it goes there's the new
york times homepage and there's a cnet
news homepage
rss feeds in tech news so i'm going to
exit out of this and just see
um there are right now
14 unread
article titles
that i can scroll through
just if i want to look at them so that's
that's pretty decent that is the quick
and easy way
to install or not to install but to view
and manage your rss feeds in thunderbird
now i have a tech news account for rss i
could add a second account for maybe um
i don't know watching my socks if i
wanted to add another one
for that feed i could do a google news
one
so um
yeah that's the simple way to add
simple way to add um rss feeds in
thunderbird so i hope you like this
video and if you like it go ahead and
subscribe and if you have any other
video tutorials you'd like me to make
about any program you can think of i do
a lot of software reviews so go ahead
and subscribe and pm me and ask for a
video so thanks for watching guys peace